il y aune roger bonjour merci d'être
avec nous consultant pour france 24 les
affaires stratégiques
on s'attendait évidemment à ces deux ces
deux sons de cloche chacun pousse ses
pions sur cette carte ukrainienne la
russie qui dément avoir frappé on va y
revenir avec marina un hôpital
pédiatrique occupée par les passions ce
ne sont uniquement des combattants
séparatistes ukrainien qui s'y tenait ça
fait partie évidemment de la rhétorique
en temps de guerre et en est toute façon
dans une guerre de communication c'est
extrêmement complexe pour nous
compliquer de de vérifier en tout cas ce
qui s'est passé hier tout ça reste très
logique finalement même si cette
terrible avoir à dire très logique dans
une guerre oui ça fait surtout quand on
part du principe que aujourd'hui les
russes souhaitent gagner du temps et
qu'on reste quelle que soit la réponse à
la question ils ont peiné à envahir will
continue de peiner envir le pays ou bien
ils le font à dessein à leur rythme en
quelque sorte pour avoir le temps de
d'économiser des forces et de voir
comment réagissent les ukrainiens pour
aussi aussi de favoriser une forme de
deux millions de fatigue de la
population et des connexions entre la
population ukrainienne et son
gouvernement éventuellement été bref
beaucoup de questions sur la sur
l'aspect tactique mais on voit bien que
la radio filmée convenu pour les rues
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup parlé de
guerre éclair que souhaité vladimir
poutine ça s'installe ça fait deux
semaines tout juste aujourd'hui et on
est encore loin des résultats même si
globalement les forces russes progress
l'estrie physique puis encore une fois
quel résultat quels résultats c'est à
dire est-ce que c'est d'abord
une forme de concrétisation de la
conquête de l'est et un peu du sud enfin
on a beaucoup parlé des enseignants
semaine qu'est ce que c'est
véritablement une volonté un 2-2 de
disloquer l'ukraine actuelle est de
laisser finalement peut-être un résidu
un petit état autour de l'eau vive à
l'ouest bref beaucoup de questions sur
finalement la rationalité l'objectif
final pour l'instant ces derniers temps
mais y ait une dimension surréaliste on
pouvait peut-être s'attendre à un
discours diplomatique russe ici à
antalya un peu un tout petit peu plus
réaliste donc c'est quand même ça
quichotte serment le déni en bloc on
constate ça ensuite une autre question
par rapport à lyon à la halle aspects
diplomatiques en pensant un peu plus
loin c'est que finalement il lavrov a
rappelé
la vraie discussion elle se fait pour
l'instant en ville aussi elle se fait
avec des acteurs directs ukrainiens et
russes il est venu en quelque sorte
comme le dit lui-même à la demande de la
turquie henri ton revient derrière qu'il
ya quand même la volonté de maintenir
plusieurs fers au feu et de maintenir
avec erdogan quand même l'option d'un
tiers d'un intermédiaire qu'il ya
beaucoup d'intérêts on leur en chinois c
est tout à fait mais la ccsi donc là on
a quelqu'un qui al'avantage quand même
d'avoir un pied en europe la turquie 1
qu'on le veuille ou non et géographie
européenne un jour efi régional est un
pays qui aident les deux pays qui est de
toute façon avant une fouille d'intérêt
d'intérêt tactique et stratégique a
essayé de se proposer en tout cas sinon
de s'imposer comme médiateur donc voilà
je crois qu'il y avait si on peut garder
un tout petit signe positif dans ces
c'est qu'effectivement il ya comme une
petite porte laisse ouverte la turquie
tout le reste malheureusement n'est que
guillaume de rouge et ghislaine roger à
part la loi parce qu'on parle en même
temps c'est vrai que finalement cette
rhétorique russe elle n'a pas changé
d'un iota depuis le début de cette crise
mais quand on a suivi on a décidé de
prendre les questions de la presse à
sergueï lavrov sans presse s'est étendue
dans le temps il ya eu moult questions
qui ont été posées notamment sur les
réelles intentions de là la russie est
ce que la russie veut déclarer une
troisième guerre mondiale est ce qu'elle
est prête à attaquer à s'engager dans
une guerre nucléaire aujourd'hui avec
d'autres états qui aide l'ukraine qui
arment l'ukraine aujourd'hui on connaît
la réaction de moscou vis-à-vis de ça
beaucoup de questions formulées sur la
réalité des intentions on sent bien que
derrière en occident on a du mal à
croire les russes aujourd'hui
vous voulez lire à les croire sur le sur
la réalité d'une menace qui peut
escalader cette question de la menace a
été posée à plusieurs reprises par la
presse on a dit on a du mal à les croire
actuellement sur leur volonté de
dialoguer en revanche je croirais
al'inverse au risque d'être un peu
provocateur qu'on les croit peut-être
trop dans l'agitation de la menace
nucléaire c'est à dire que on a on a vu
justement les différents gouvernements
occidentaux réagir la mère est plus posé
qui soit et parfois d'ailleurs par une
forme d'indifférence sur les différentes
ça nous arrange ça ça que vous dites non
non ce que je veux dire c'est que il ne
faut pas faux passion jouer les
véritables véritable démarche qu'on
entreprend pour pour bien disons un
indiqué aux russes qu on est à l'écouté
à la fois pour le dialogue mais aussi
pour nous montrer déterminé si vous
voulez si les russes souhaitaient
disons à gravir certains barreaux de
l'échelle des ce cas là c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est nous véritablement
sur une ligne de crête on souhaite aider
l'ukraine mais absolument donné
absolument aucun prétexte à la russie
pour éventuellement engager un conflit
contre d'autres états bien sûr les états
de l'alliance mais aussi peut-être
éventuellement la moldavie et à des
ondes et des états qui font partie des
états qui souhaite à terme ça c'est des
vrais questions qui vont être posées ce
soir à versailles aux dirigeants des 27
vous pensez qu'on va voir ses réponses
je pense je pense que c'est un ensemble
que lui eu lieu à toute sa part à jouer
à la fois sur le plan civil sur le plan
militaire pour me dire qu'ils mentent
plan civil sur la clé sanctions et avec
d'une façon générale une détermination
il faut pas oublier que la dissuasion ce
n'est pas seulement survivre et
répliquer c'est aussi à la
proportionnalité c'est la crédiblité de
leadership et sérénité aux tic capacité
à engager toute une société a donc à
partir du moment où on reste très unie
sur tous les aspects civils on envoie
d'une manière ou d'une autre
indirectement certes mais on l'envoie un
message détermination et d'union et
ensuite tout ce qu'on peut faire un
niveau je dirais
sub conventionnel au niveau de
l'assistance à l'ukraine sur le plan
militaire qui ne soit pas on l'a vu hier
le miracle l'incident est clos on va pas
envoyer des avions de combat à l'ukraine
on peut pas le faire non mais on en voit
quand même d'autres types d'armement oui
on l'a vu dans les reportages là
particulièrement efficace là encore est
finie pour les russes en fait en fait
tout tout tout dépend d'eux encore une
fois du prétexte dans la manière dont
c'est parce que il ya évidemment la
réalité et ils vont les russes savent
qu'on cherche à aider ukrainien et en
même temps il ya toute la logique en
fait de 1 2 lors de la 10e la manière
dont les ukrainiens vont pouvoir eux
même âge il n'est pas question par
exemple d'infiltrer des forces
occidentales et c'est vraiment toute
cette ligne de crête et à partir de là
les ce qui se passe sur le terrain ce
qui va se passer sur le terrain dans les
prochains jours on va nous dire si
effectivement il ya vraiment cette ce
basculement dans une guerre non
conventionnelle si cette guerre de siège
s'installe cette guerre d'usure
s'installe merci guillaume de roger
reste